Yeah,
it's great to be here today. And, uh,
it's a tremendous honor to get to
chat with Jimmy Wales. So Jimmy,
why don't you come on? Um, so
first of all,
everybody knows [inaudible]
if you go on, if you go to
Wikipedia, you'll notice that his,
a drawing of him or a picture of him
appears asking you to give money.
So if you're one of the hundreds of
millions of people who go to Wikipedia
practically every day, um, you'll
know his face. This is him.
It's not like Colonel Sanders.
He actually exists. Uh,
so just by a little bit of background.
So Jamie started Wikipedia in 2001,
uh,
he launched with Kia in 2004,
which is much more focused
on entertainment and games
and is one of the top 20
websites worldwide.
And in 2015,
he started the Wikipedia foundation
and most recently this year he started
something called Wiki Tribune
with the goal to fight fake news.
And,
um,
you described it as news by
the people and for the people.
And the first time that professional
journalists and citizen journalists will
work side by side. So, uh, let's go back.
Let's rewind back to when you
started. You've described, um,
the initial group that helped you
start Wikipedia is a, I'm quoting here,
rag tag band of volunteers.
If you can remember back,
what was it like to start something that
has become such a worldwide phenomenon?
Yeah, well, I mean this was in the
very, very early days of Wikipedia.
We were just a, you know, a really a
small group of people. And, uh, you know,
before Wikipedia had a
project called new PDF,
which has the same goal to have
a free encyclopedia for everyone.
But I didn't really
understand online communities.
I didn't have any idea
about the concept of a Wiki.
And so we organized a very top down
system with [inaudible] as a review to get
anything published. Uh,
and that was a failure.
It was a failure mainly because it was
really intimidating for anybody to get
involved. Um, and uh,
we have the course of a year,
uh,
we had created about two
dozen entries. Um, I joke,
I still keep them by my bed and
read them every night. I thought,
we'll get my money's worth someday. What
were, what were some of the, to do death.
They were just very eclectic.
Uh,
but I mean there were so few that and
there were very academic and so forth. Um,
and then, you know, really realized
that that wasn't working and, uh,
decided to pivot,
although nobody called it pivot back then,
but nobody should call it
that anymore. Yeah, exactly.
I'm about done with that word.
Um, and launched the Wiki.
Uh, and in two weeks we had as
much work done as we had, uh, in,
well it was actually nearly two years. So,
uh, so that was the, the very beginning.
And the truth is in the, in
the very early days, I mean,
the software was in no kind of state.
Um, I had downloaded a used model Wiki,
which was a pearl, um, script,
very simple wiki package.
Uh, it was so simple in fact that
there were, there were no passwords.
So you could create a user name,
but you didn't have a password.
So anybody could pretend to be anybody,
um, which clearly doesn't scale very well.
Um, so one of the first things I did
was sort of right, you know, a password,
uh, sort of, uh, ability
to have a password and uh,
but still what was great about Wikis is,
is the word Wiki.
It comes from a Hawaiian word Wiki Wiki
meaning quick, quick collaboration.
Like people were able to just turn in
because although we had been going for
about two years and
hadn't gotten much done,
there were a lot of people who were super
interested in super excited about this
concept of a free
encyclopedia for everyone. Um,
and so we were able to
pretty quickly move forward,
but we were able to do it. I
mean, there was no, like again,
people didn't say minimal
viable product back then.
It was just like this crappy perl script
and we were just in sort of doing stuff
on a day to day basis to
try and make it better.
When you take apart Wikipedia as
you really founded an invented it,
there's a couple of unique things.
One of them is that practically,
but anybody can post one of the others
that that isn't so parent is this massive
community of people who totally unpaid
and a lot of cases totally anonymous who
edit and make sure that every entry
fits to really tip to you to Wikipedia
standards.
Yeah, I mean I think there's
a few elements of that that
are really important to
understand. So first of all, I,
you know, the word community,
a online community as much abused and
oftentimes what people mean by that,
it's just the general public. But for
me, when I use the word community,
it's people who actually know each other.
Uh, and they're discussing and debating.
They're actually making
decisions. Uh, and so it,
if your mental model of how Wikipedia
works is 100 million people adding one
sentence each and it magically becomes
an encyclopedia, that isn't the case.
It's really a core group of
volunteers who enforced the rules,
who decide what the rules are,
um,
who put into place organize procedures
and processes to monitor things,
to update things.
Uh,
just as one example is the
concept of a wiki project.
So one of my favorite wiki
project is wiki project bridges.
So this is a group of people who
are really interested in bridges,
the architecture,
the history,
and they go through all of Wikipedia and
they find all the articles having easier
experts,
interested amateurs.
Um, a mix actually. So I,
one of the guys who I met who was one of
the leaders of the Wiki project bridges
is an architect. Um, but
many of the people aren't,
they're just interested hobbyists.
Uh,
and so they go through all these articles
and they come up with checklists of,
okay,
what does a good bridge article look like?
What does it mean to have included which
ones don't have those elements and can
we research and find that?
And so there's a lot of that kind of
work that goes on beneath the surface and
it really is small groups who
know each other, who say, okay,
well we're going to take on this
particular topic. Another fantastic one,
a particularly strong in English.
Wikipedia is wiki project medicine. Uh,
and they are quite fearsome in there.
Uh,
demands that the rules be followed
because the medical topics or, you know,
people rely on it. It's really
important that I be, uh, are very,
very careful about things that could
mislead the public and so forth. So,
uh, yeah. So, and why
do people contribute?
Is it you talked about a community
of people that know each other.
Is it a dedication to it?
Is it prestige among the other people
that they know in this community? So,
so it's, uh, it's a couple of
things. Um, so first of all,
the vision of free encyclopedia for every
single person on the planet in their
own language is exciting. Uh, people
think that's worth spending time on.
So, you know, if you're someone
you could have, you know,
you could spend the weekend playing
grand theft auto, uh, and then, you know,
late Sunday night you realize you've
just wasted two days of your life, uh,
that you'll never get back and you haven't
improved the world. Very productive.
Uh, or you can, you know,
work on Wikipedia and
whatever may come of it. You,
you come away thinking,
Hey, you know what?
The world's a little bit better
now than it was when I started.
So that Grand Vision, uh, is
important, but also it has to be fun.
People have to find it interesting.
You have to meet other Nice,
interesting people who are, uh, you know,
you're learning things and you're
meeting people and you're having quality
debates, uh, which is hard
to come by on the Internet.
There's plenty of places to have
sort of raging flame wars, uh,
but to actually have an interesting
discussion or debate around the quality of
sourcing around some particular
topic, um, people enjoy that.
And so it's gotta be both of
those gotta be, you know, that,
that we feel like we're doing something
productive and we're also are enjoying
it. And so, yeah, it does have
something to do with not prestige.
So if you want to become a
well known famous person, uh,
on the Internet, I would recommend
being a blogger or something like that.
You know, uh, spend your
time on social media. Uh,
but so within the
Wikipedia community though,
we aren't particularly at
anonymous with each other.
People do know each other and people
have respect and people don't know each
other virtually, or do they actually know
each other in person? Mostly virtually.
But it depends. Uh, it actually, that
depends very much on the language.
So if you think about,
uh, for example, uh,
Lithuanian Wikipedia,
virtually everyone who speaks
Lithuanian lives within a train, right,
of each other.
Uh,
and so they tend to have and they get
together for a beer and they actually know
each other pretty well. Uh, other
languages like English of course,
is spread all around the world. And so
often has people talking to each other,
but people do meet up, they
meet up locally, uh, they
meet up all over the world.
We have our conferences
and things like that.
Of course, one of the topics
and putting aside the, the,
the last election board
and the topics overall is,
is verifying information. And, uh,
everybody's a aware of some
of the famous Wikipedia hacks.
So for example,
uh,
I used to run MTV networks and one of our
companies is Nickelodeon and there was
the Wikipedia page for
both mnm and sponge.
Bob said that m and m was
the voice of Spongebob.
Now I can assure you that was not the
case or Steven called bear from comedy
Central,
um,
convinced his audience to change
Wikipedia to say that elephants were not
endangered.
What,
what needs to happen to
ensure that these entries,
whether it's about popular culture or
about medicine or about architecture,
what happens to make sure that,
that they're verified?
Yeah, just as an example. So they, uh,
when Colburn made this joke on the air,
literally within 30 seconds of him
saying the joke, the page was locked,
uh, because the Wikipedia is
actually watched Kobe or two.
So the Admin is just winning to lock
the page immediately, uh, and vandalism.
And then we had to cope with it for like
three weeks as people kept trying to
put it in. But we just
kept the page lock. Um,
I didn't have time. You mentioned the
Eminem when I had not heard that one.
I'm guessing that probably only lasted
in, in Wikipedia for again, a few minutes.
Um, I think I know why there's actually,
I saw it on youtube. There's a,
uh, spongebob and, uh,
lose yourself mash up on youtube
has like 4 million views.
So that's probably where it came from.
That probably became a meme and
then people thought it was funny to,
to have that. Uh, so, and that
sort of thing, it does happen. Uh,
usually it's very, very short term.
Uh, and you know, sometimes it isn't.
Sometimes you can have vandalism in
Wikipedia that lasts much longer than we
would like, so it isn't perfect. Um, but
the way it works that we have to have,
you know, if you, again,
if you have the model of Wikipedia is
100 million people all randomly putting
stuff in, it would just be, that's
all it would be is just nonsense. Um,
but we have a whole bunch of
different, uh, policies, procedures,
uh, people become admins, they're
elected by the community, and then, uh,
they have the ability and admins
are not like in most sites.
So like if you're on youtube
and you do something,
it's the rules of youtube
in your page gets taken,
your video gets taken down
and you're locked out.
You actually have no idea who did that.
Somebody's mysterious, deepen, uh,
Google somewhere.
Did it.
Whereas in our community that the
admins are all members of the public,
they're all volunteers and
they monitor each other.
And there's always debates about,
oh, was this a valid block?
Why don't you block this person?
Uh, et Cetera, et cetera.
So they're more like a police.
Um, you know, they're not judge,
jury and executioner. They have certain
abilities to block. People are like pages,
but they have to justify that.
And there are ways that those decisions
can be reviewed and overturned and so
forth. So it's, it's like managing
a good municipal government really.
So we have 100 million,
uh, users of Wikipedia is how
many people, I mean, this number,
we, we, we want to know how many
people are actually editing today.
Yeah. So if you, if you take a
look at the number, so the, the,
the best number we have right now is,
uh, for the number of unique devices,
the access Wikipedia and a
month is about 1.4 billion.
So that's a lot of people.
It's not 1.4 billion people because
probably most people in this room,
for example,
access Wikipedia in a month on
at least two or three devices.
But it's a huge audience.
And then just to give the numbers for
English Wikipedia, there's probably, um,
about 70 to 80,000 people who make
at least five minutes in a month,
uh, and there's about 3000 people who make
a at least a hundred edits in a month.
So it's that 3000 who are the really
active community who really oversee and
manage things. And then there's lots
of people who just add one thing,
which then is reviewed by the
community and so forth. It's pretty,
pretty extraordinary. It's 3000. Yeah.
People who, who really make the
really changed the world for the,
for the rest of us you've talked about.
Got, you know, it's funny, I was, uh,
a few years back, it just struck me.
I was at Wiki mania as our annual
conference and I had a dinner. I just,
you know, my tray. I went and sat
and I was, okay, look, here's the,
the English arbitration committee.
So this is the,
like the Supreme Court of
English, Wikipedia. Um,
and we're having dinner and discussing
this, that, and the other policy.
And I left the table and I thought,
you know,
I get to meet a lot of important people,
but this is probably some of the most
powerful people in media in the world is
the English, Wikipedia,
arbitration committee. I mean,
they make really big decisions and
they're like a bunch of geeks and nobody,
nobody stick. Nobody outside
their community knows them.
Not really. No. I mean,
occasionally you'll get
a news article about,
uh, somebody who's had the most number
of edits and that sort of thing.
And oftentimes the people who,
if you've had the most number of edits,
oftentimes they're running a
Bot. A, that's how you get up.
Very high edit count is to spell checking
or something like that. Not always. Um,
and they're generally
known in the community,
but they aren't always necessarily the
most influential or powerful within the
company. They're just like really
busy as the main thing. So in general,
now nobody really knows who they
are. I mean we do, but yeah.
But you've also talked a lot
about AI machine learning.
What role will that play in
verifying information in the future?
So,
I mean, what's interesting about this
is sometimes people ask it this way,
or when do you think AI will be
able to write Wikipedia articles?
And I say it's a very long time or,
anyway,
it's one of the highest human activities
is to write a good Wikipedia entry is
really quite a fan. I mean, once we're
there, we're, we're at full general AI.
It's the singularity and let's
just hope they're nice to us. Um,
and, but before that, um, I do think
there's some interesting things. Uh,
we have a partnership with
the Jigsaw, uh, where we, uh,
it's AI looking at edits and,
and machine learning.
I don't actually know very little
about it except it's really cool. Um,
so on Wikipedia,
if you're logged in,
you can go to recent changes in now you
can filter the recent changes and you
can save whatever filter and there's
different things you can select.
So what I do,
this is just my favorite way of filtering.
I want to see edits that
are very likely bad,
that are likely in good
faith by new users. So this
is somebody new to the site.
They've made an edit,
which is probably bad,
but it was probably made in good faith
and it actually is pretty good at finding
those. And then you what you do.
Then the reason I picked those as,
that's the kind of people that just
go say hi, like, hi, thanks. You know,
it looks like you're trying to do
this. Uh, let's, you know, and, uh,
that's kind of amazing.
So being able to,
I think what is interesting here is the
idea of AI basically just, you know,
raising the hand,
raising the flag for a human to review
something because it often gets it wrong.
You wouldn't really want AI policing this
sort of thing. So it's assisted review,
it's assisted review. Um, and I
think that's very useful, uh, to,
and I think this is an area we
will pursue more in various ways.
And Ai is a very broad term,
but the idea of using much
more algorithmic approaches
to bring things to the
attention of people, uh, that
you're probably interested.
So just as an example to,
um, interest new editors, what we
could do is notice what you're reading.
And so if we see,
okay,
every day you're reading about World
War II and we have over here on article
that we have algorithmic signals is
not very good. We could say, Hey,
you've been reading a lot about World
War II, would you like to help out?
Here's an article that leads
to improvement in recruitment.
Yeah, exactly. Um, and,
or if you're editing, you know,
in an area, then we can say, oh,
here's some similar things that
you might want to edit that,
that need help and that sort of thing.
And we've been very,
very human about all that sort of thing.
We don't have much in the way of
algorithms to look at that sort of thing,
but I think there's huge
opportunities there. Um, and,
and the great thing about assisted
review or prompting people,
it doesn't have to be perfect to be a lot
better than nothing. Um, you know, if,
if it,
if we can start suggesting things to me
that I should edit and I think half of
them are useless and half of them
are actually kind of interesting,
that's better than suggesting zero to me.
So how does the community feel about,
um, AI did not feel that they should put
some standard around the ta? Yeah, yeah.
They're very, they're very,
um, protective of, uh,
of their turf in a certain way.
But they're also very, these are,
these are quite geeky people.
They're interested in technology.
They're open to saying,
yeah,
there's a lot of stuff that humans
aren't very good at that machine,
like very tedious,
boring stuff.
If we can get that machines do that
stuff and raise it to our attention,
then our work is more effective.
Because as I said in the beginning,
one of the reasons people want to edit
Wikipedia is at the end of an hour
editing Wikipedia, if you feel like you
did something useful, that's important.
And so if I go to Wikipedia and I picked
some obscure article and try to improve
a couple of sentences,
I'm never quite sure,
is anybody even going to read that or
whatever. But if you show me like, Oh,
here's a popular article
that is in poor state, okay,
that I'll have an impact if I do that.
So I think people like that sort of idea.
Um,
let's shift gears.
Let's talk about education itself.
I have a personal experience. I
have two 18 year olds, uh, uh,
boy and girl, and they've
gone through school. Um,
and one is already in college and
their entire time through school,
their teachers have said,
Wikipedia is not a source.
You can't use Wikipedia. You
have to go. And by the way,
the first place that they go for anything
is Wikipedia, but it's never disclosed.
Um,
and
you can tell kids, don't listen to
rock and roll music, but we're well,
well past that, right? No, it's actually
more important. It's what you, you,
you protect your parents from doing,
uh, and it's your responsibility.
So,
but coming back to what's,
what is it that we could pedia and
other organizations that are around
information, what, what, what's their
responsibility? What's the opportunity?
So for us, I mean, we, we
feel a very heavy burden. Um,
if we think about, uh,
well 18 year olds, right?
So Wikipedia is now 16 years old.
So from the time they were
learning to read Wikipedia existed,
it's certainly in the last five years,
a five to 10 years when they were old
enough to start doing homework and looking
online or following their own intellectual
interests, whatever that might be,
they go to Wikipedia.
And so it's just part of the
infrastructure of the world
as far as their concern,
which means we have a responsibility
to make it as good as we possibly can.
And when I say we, I include everyone
in this room. I mean, this is a,
it's a public resource.
Um, and uh, but what,
but it's important to, to know, we don't
consider it to be a goal for Wikipedia,
that we be sizable source.
Um, for 18 years old, uh,
entering college any more
than when I was at university,
if I cited Botanica, that would have been
considered ludicrous. That's something,
you know,
and encyclopedia,
that's not the role they should play in
the research process in secular media is
the starting point, not the ending
point. Particularly at the college level.
It's like, Hey, if all
you're going to do is look,
read Wikipedia and write a paper, I
mean, come on, this is ridiculous.
Read Wikipedia to get oriented,
but then go to the original sources and
doing more interesting intellectual work.
Now,
of course,
if a 13 year old writes something and
adds a footnote and sites Wikipedia,
I'm like, hey, you know, progress.
At least they've written something
and they put it in a footnote.
That's okay at a certain age,
but later on,
I don't think that it's not
something we aspire to. Um,
you know,
said.
Do you think Wikipedia or
other organizations with
Wikipedia have more of a role
in education? I mean, education
is a huge challenge for sure. Not,
not every kid in this country is going
to get to go to college. Uh, what, what,
what, what can we could PD
and other organizations do to,
to solve our education problem?
Well, I mean, I think one of
the things that's going on,
if you look at the trends
in formal education,
so what percentage of
people are going to college?
That moves around a very little bit,
but it's pretty stable and nothing
dramatic is happening there.
A few more people are going to college,
a few lessons,
certain places and certain things.
But in general,
that's a pretty well understood area.
But what is completely
changed in the last 10,
15 years is the amount of informal
learning that people do that,
you know, if, if you hear of
directed self directed, uh,
even just ordinary thing. So if
you here, um, oh, I dunno, blah,
blah blah,
there's something going on called bitcoin.
I don't really know what that is.
Uh, you know, if it was 25 years ago,
you would go, I don't know, I
read this article in the paper.
I don't really get it now. People dig
deep and we see this in our traffic.
You know, people can dictate
all the information's there. Um,
and that's really important and it doesn't
result in more degrees and so forth.
But people can learn about anything
they want to learn about very easily.
And that is a huge impact on education.
I do think there's a lot to think about.
So for us,
one of the biggest things that we are
interested in is the growth of Wikipedia
in the languages of the developing world.
Because of course there are places in
the world where people have very limited
access to information.
So what was the way I think about
this is if you're an English speaker,
one of the things is the solution to
is just narrowing down a place to go to
find basic information. So if I type Queen
Victoria into Google, I'm going to get,
I dunno, millions of pages, the number
one, it's probably going to be Wikipedia.
That's probably what I wanted.
I just wanted to get the basic story
of Queen Victoria, her life and times.
It's all there. And this is because
we have a glut of information.
But if you're a, you know,
if you're speaking, um,
a, an obscure language, uh,
with only a million speakers
and Africa in your language,
there's going to be like the
role of Wikipedia is, hey,
it's the only source I have
for Queen Victoria. Uh,
it's the only place I can go for that
information. And not yet in many cases,
we're just really getting started
in a lot of those languages.
So there's a lot of work left to do,
but it's interesting how that
impact will be different, uh,
because instead of being saying,
oh, we've got a glut of information,
let's summarize it in an encyclopedia
article. Like we have no information.
So let's share it with, uh, you
know, people, uh, in this way.
Um,
the,
the nature of how people interact
with the web is changing dramatically.
And so we,
everyone's aware of the voice interface,
but the reality is the digital assistant,
whether it's Alexa,
Google assist or a well
or okay Google or Siri,
um, the, these are one of the ways in
which people will access information.
How will Wikipedia adapt
to those new interfaces?
So, uh, it is very interesting. I mean,
we are an important part of those
interfaces already. Um, you know,
if you ask Alexa a question,
99% of the time she's just going to
read Wikipedia to you or get a fact from
Wikipedia. Obviously Google relies a lot
on Wikipedia for the knowledge graph.
Uh, I don't actually use
the Google assistant because
I have Alexa at home. Uh,
assume it's very similar, although I
heard that if you ask Google a question,
it says according to Wikipedia,
thank you.
Whereas Alexa just acts like she knows
everything even though she's just reading
it out of Wikipedia.
So, uh, so there's that.
I need to email Jeff and
it's about that. But, um,
but what's interesting for me to ask you
the question, I don't know. I tried Siri,
didn't understand what
I was saying. So, so,
uh, in any event,
basically what we're, um,
what's interesting to us about that
is w and one of the areas that we,
we do slightly worry about it,
but we don't have firm evidence yet.
One of the words we have is, and
we're not a business, we're a charity,
so we don't think much about business
model and we've never been very good at
thinking about business model.
Um,
we just are a group of people who are
enjoying making this encyclopedia and
we're really happy that
everybody likes it.
But realistically we do have to think
about that. And so right now, uh,
the way Wikipedia gets money to survive
is you come to the website and there's a
little banner. Um, very rarely, but yes,
you know, once a year you see
your photo does very well.
Yeah,
we haven't been using it in recent years.
I'm very happy we found this ugly yellow
banner that no one on Madison Avenue
would think would work, but it works
beautifully. Uh, and actually we are,
we are more and more our fundraising is
through the email campaign because our,
our donors are very loyal and if you
donate to Wikipedia a year later,
you get a message from me,
which I may or may not have
actually written a that says, hey,
it's been a year of time to
cough up again. And, and it,
and it gets a really good response.
Um, but, and so that's a good,
that's a good news. What we worry
about is, I call it the, the, the,
how old is Tom Cruise problem. So five
years ago, 10 years ago, if you typed,
how old is Tom cruise into Google?
The first link was Wikipedia and you go
there and you find out how old was Tom
Cruise.
Now the first link is still Wikipedia,
but up above that it tells you how we'll
talk this because Google understands
the much better Google read Wikipedia for
one thing. And uh, and so we think, okay,
well does that mean we're not seeing
that traffic and does that mean we're not
going to get the donations from people?
So far we don't have any evidence
of that. Uh, and in fact,
because the knowledge graph
does link to Wikipedia, I mean,
we see a lot of traffic from that,
so it hasn't yet heard us.
But when we think then about a voice
assistant, um, if people are just saying,
uh,
who is Tom Cruise?
And you get three sentences from
Wikipedia and people don't know you're
concerned about attribution,
concerned about attribution and
epit even if there is attribution,
are people going to donate?
We don't know. So far so good.
But that is one thing and
our view is again, the,
the fundamental,
you know,
the Vision Statement for Wikipedia is
imagine a world in which every single
person on the planet has given free
access to the sum of all human knowledge.
That's what we're doing.
And so in that front and the community's
view on this sort of thing is it's
fucking fantastic.
Like amazing.
We compete as part of the
infrastructure of the world.
All these new technologies are coming out.
The knowledge that we've
carefully stewarded and
written is now helping people,
you know, um, you know, when
did Fred Astaire die? Right?
You have that thought in
your kitchen for two seconds.
You can ask Alexa and she
tells you amazing, right?
We don't need to get paid for that.
That's where a charity for,
we want everybody to
have access to knowledge.
But there is a little bit
of a question about, okay,
how does our business model
work if in 20 years, you know,
as technology changes, we don't want
to let Wikipedia get left behind. So,
but so far we're, I mean we're,
we're doing great financially,
so we always run in a
very conservative way. Um,
we asked for money, sometimes
we were getting criticism, uh,
from I think rather stupid
press outlets who say,
why is Wikipedia begging for money?
They have 100 million in the bank. Um,
and it's like, well, you know, our
annual budget's about 70 million.
So we have about 18 months reserve.
That's considered to be a healthy
level of reserves for a nonprofit.
We're not apologetic about that. Um,
but you know, every year we've been,
last year, well, thanks to the president,
um, it was not necessarily big fan of us,
but who has motivated people to care
about knowledge? Uh, in a roundabout way.
Um,
the day from the day after the election,
we saw a massive increase in donations.
Um,
which was very heartwarming to see
because, uh, you know, and, and we'll,
we'll get onto fake news in a bit when we,
when we're talking about
a Wiki Tribune, but, um,
but we've decided we are also
raising an endowment fund, um,
because we do think of ourselves not
so much as a, I mean we're not a.com.
We're not a tech startup.
We're a charity sharing knowledge
and we try to think in the long run.
And so one of the things we
say is, look, while we're,
while we're not in desperate
financial situation,
we should be thinking about the
longterm future. So we've now got,
we're raising a hundred million
dollar endowment fund, um, and we're,
I think we've got pledges
for about 17 million so far.
And it's really the first time that we've
really tried to have more of a major
donor campaign because the vast majority
of the money for Wikipedia comes from
those, you know, you see the banner
and you give 20 bucks and you know,
that's the vast majority of money.
And we've never been really good at
doing major donor stuff. But this is,
we think this is an interesting product.
You might call it for a major donor to
site, don't just fund our annual budget.
Think about the future.
We want,
we keep PD and the idea of be
to be safe in the long run.
So we won't have this fund for any
future emergencies or any future
opportunities. And we've done it all the
right way. We've got a separate board.
So there's another layer of governance.
So it's not just a big bank account for
some future profligate CEO and so forth.
So, so far so good. Um, I'm going to ask
everybody for questions a little later,
so please start thinking about them.
But in the meantime,
I'd like to welcome or eat cuts of health.
Use Your, um, your cofounder of Wiki.
Truebeam yes. So Ori, you were somewhere.
Okay.
Hi. So welcome. So what should
we know about Wiki Tribune?
Um, do, let's start. I'll have to let her
start because I'm terrible about just,
I could sit here and talk.
Uh, how many of you have heard of
wicked driven? Oh, that's great. Okay.
It's Google here. So,
um, it's a new inventive,
a news platform which evolves generally's
him in a way that has never been done
before by bringing together a Wiki
based community of volunteers and hired
professional journalist in an effort
to create a collaborative new space and
high quality open platform,
which is genuinely community
controlled and have the bay,
the backbone of professional journalists.
And so we practically,
I attend the community volunteers and the
hire journalists as equals and it is a
wiki based platform so everyone can
edit every article on our website.
So, um, but how do you
ensure freedom of expression?
And this is not just,
this isn't just journalists,
these are individuals who are today
posting to social media. First of all,
what do we need to protect
them from? Yeah, so I think
we ensure expression. Yeah.
One thing I wanted to explain because
there was a little error in the
introduction in 2015,
uh,
I didn't set up the Wikipedia foundation.
The Wikimedia foundation has been
around for a long time. In 2015,
I set up the Jimmy Wales, uh, Jimmy Lewis
Foundation for freedom of expression,
which is a nonprofit based in the UK.
When what we do is we,
we fight for mainly for social media
users, so people who aren't covered.
So reporters without borders does a
fantastic job of working to a highlight
cases of journalists being arrested.
But a lot of times ordinary people who
say something and get themselves arrested,
a political speech to get a bit ignored.
And so we try to campaign for those
people and so forth. And we'll re uh,
is the CEO of the Jimmy Wales Foundation.
Uh, and that's a separate piece of work,
uh, from Wiki attribute, which is a
project. Uh, Jimmy was foundation that,
that what happened there,
I went to Dubai, uh,
to give a speech as I do. And when I
landed they said, oh, congratulations. Uh,
the leader of Dubai has decided to give
you a half a million dollars as the
knowledge award. Uh, and I was like,
okay, fine. It sounds all right.
But then I went back to my room
and I was like, you know, I'm,
I'm like super critical of
Dubai on human rights issues,
a freedom of expression and so forth,
so I can't in good conscience take
this money and buy a boat. Um,
and so that was when I said,
okay, I'm going to take the money,
which is from a bad source in my opinion.
I don't want to give it back
to him so he can, you know,
hire more people to beat bloggers.
Um,
instead I'll use it to fight
for freedom of expression.
So that's when we started
working together on that. Um,
and so that's been great fun. Okay.
So then explain Wiki Tribune please.
All so we can Tribune. Uh, so we
contribute and we just started this year,
uh, or you get the basic concept of
it. A little of the history. We, um,
we decided to launch using
a crowdfunding campaign. Uh,
and I really am a big fan of
crowd funding as you know, as a,
as an entrepreneur starting something new.
Um,
I could have easily gone in and raise
money in silicon valley to do it,
but I don't know if the public
is interested. Do they want this?
And so saying to people, Hey, will
you sign up to contribute? Uh,
and the business model is, um, we,
we asked people to become
monthly supporters. Uh,
we have no paywall and no advertising.
So a series of bad business decisions,
but it's how I built my
career so far. Um, and, uh,
but I didn't know. I'm like, well, that
even work when people would be interested.
So we did a crowdfunding campaign,
not on Kickstarter or anywhere like that.
We just did it sort of independently. Um,
and we've got a great, you know, I said,
look, I need enough money to hard 10
journalists, uh, had some tech people.
And so we managed to do that. Uh, we
also got a, a lovely grant from Google,
Google Digital News Initiative in
Europe, uh, to develop the software. Uh,
we've got,
we're using,
we're taking wordpress as a platform
and turning it into a Wiki. And it,
as it turns out,
wordpress doesn't want to be a Wiki a.
So there's a lot of eating on it
to make that, uh, more, uh, uh,
useful in that regard.
Um,
and we went into like closed
Beta for a while and then now,
just two weeks ago we've opened,
you can go and sign up and
you can start editing things.
And we've got now 13 journalists hired,
some of them are part time,
but 10 full time equivalents, um,
around the world, but mostly in London,
which is where I live. And
that's, that's where we are today.
And we were publishing stories. So go
to, we contributed and you can see it.
So what is just for this group to
understand what is the problem that Wiki
Tribune solves versus what we can meet?
We compete. We can pdf death today. Yeah.
So, um, so Wikipedia is not news.
There's a page and Wikipedia,
this is not news. We're
not news. Now, of course,
Wikipedia quite famously does update
very quickly when news events happen.
But it doesn't cover every single thing
as it's happening. And also in Wikipedia,
uh, one of the fundamental
rules is no original research.
And so everything in Wikipedia should
have been published in a high quality
third party source.
But to do journalism,
journalism by definition
is original research. Um,
it's actually going out and getting
new stories, new information. What,
what I'm hopeful for. And the, and the
concept behind this is to say, look,
if we can find a way for a community to
usefully and productively help out, uh,
with the process of journalism,
it lowers the cost significantly.
And by lowering the cost significantly,
that means of the money
we get from readers,
more of it can be spent on
journalists. Um, you know,
if I was on the board of the Guardian
and the Guardian has lots and lots of
journalists,
it's a fantastic paper,
but they've got a lot of people doing
things inside the Guardian that I know
people would enjoy doing themselves.
There's no reason to pay
staff to do something that
people would enjoy doing, um,
if they're invited to do it. And one
of those things, uh, for example,
is policing for neutrality,
which is something that most newspapers
these days are very, very bad at.
Um, so explain to you, what do you
mean by neutrality? Neutrality?
Well,
you're familiar with it from Wikipedia.
A Wikipedia tries very hard
to be quite neutral, um,
and succeeds for the most part. And, uh,
most media outlets these
days don't even try.
I mean a few do good quality
papers, still try to be neutral. Um,
and I think if we think of
neutrality, I mean we, we had, uh,
we've been criticized on the neutrality
front from both the right and the left
applicant reviewed already. So, uh,
Breitbart had a really nasty article
about a weekend should be in.
And I was like,
great.
They're not living up to their standard
of nutrient and living to Breitbart
standard of neutrality.
No.
It basically saying we're obviously
a bunch of lefties and so on. Uh,
and then when I left
wing journalists saying,
obviously there's no such
thing as truth, so, um,
I'm exaggerating, but, uh,
but basically everybody that the simple
way to understand it philosophically is
everybody knows what bias looks like.
You know,
if we mentioned Breitbart and neutrality,
the same sentence, we all chuckle a,
because we know they don't
even try to be neutral.
Same with the Daily Mail for example. Um,
and frankly the same with the Guardian.
I love the Guardian, but they're,
they're not a neutral newspaper.
They come from a particular
liberal position. Um, and
the idea is to say, look,
actually you should try to just report
the facts in a very neutral manner and
it's important to really truck will
you get there perfectly. Of course not,
not every time,
but one of the ways that you can get there
is if you do have a healthy community
who aren't just people screaming
at each other who are saying, yeah,
actually we've got some diversity in the
community to make sure that, you know,
we're not just focusing
on one side of the issue.
We're actually taking into account
the best arguments of the other side,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So please get your questions ready.
I have one more question for Jimmy and,
or a read and then, um, and then
we'll open it up. So, um, you,
there are 3000 people in the Wikipedia
world who are probably the most important
and they're the important for everybody.
There's also us and they're
known to each other.
There's also a set of people in the
world who are maybe equally or more
important in those are the people
who create the algorithm for Google.
What should Google takeaway from what
you've been able to accomplish and the way
you see the world going forward
in terms of information?
Oh, I don't know. I mean, that's a really,
it's a really tough problem.
I mean,
so one of the things that I
think, I dunno, I have no idea.
That's a really tough
question. I, I'll just,
I'll comment in a somewhere near that.
So I was part of a group,
um, that Google asks to
help and be advising, uh,
about the right to be forgotten in Europe,
which was a huge deal in Europe.
This is a written out,
we're working together sort of a,
she was helping me write
stuff for Google and so forth.
And the issue there is that,
uh, in Europe, the, the,
the state of the law isn't, is really,
it's a disaster for freedom of expression.
Um, it's really not, not appropriate. Uh,
and the problem is the law that has been
applied by the courts is actually older
than Google. Um, the, the,
the particular case that went through was
a lawyer in Spain had had some sort of
a tax problem and his house had been
taken from him and had to be auctioned and
he,
and this was covered in the papers.
It was actually an official notice
from the courts that was in the,
in the papers.
It's still published in that paper,
but Google is not allowed to link to it,
um,
on the grounds that it's out of date,
irrelevant, et cetera. Not, to me,
that's not irrelevant at all.
If my lawyer has at his
house taken for tax reasons,
that's probably important thing about,
no. Uh, but so there you have it. So it's,
it's,
it's really a bad thing,
but there are other cases where you
can be a little more sympathetic, uh,
you know, some, um, revenge porn, uh,
things like that where if
Google is linking to it, that's
it's problematic. No, my,
my belief is that any demand to take down
content or a link to content should go
through a judge. Uh, it
shouldn't be the way it is now.
Google is mandated to be judge, jury,
and executioner on these things.
And there's not,
for publishers,
there's not a really clear right of
appeal and Google's shouldn't have that
responsibility.
And Google,
I think takes it seriously to try to
do the right thing, but it's just not,
the public policy was, is not the right
answer. But one of the things I said to,
uh, to Eric Schmidt when we were going
around and doing this, as I said, I,
we were doing hearings around,
you're hearing from all kinds of experts
on all sides of the issues. I said,
I wish we were doing these hearings two
years ago before it became a legal court
because I actually think this is a
search quality issue that for Google you
don't really want to be linking to
revenge porn and you really want to have a
well understood and well
developed editorial policy.
And of course Google traditionally has
kind of been a little reluctant to,
to say we choose to link to
things we think are quality,
where like the New York Times,
we have a right of freedom of expression.
Instead Google has preferred
to go. It's the algorithm. Uh,
and I think that may have been, I'm not
a lawyer, so I don't know, you know,
why that approach was taken.
I think it may have been a mistake because
I do think for a lot of the kinds of
things that Google is linking
to or shouldn't be linking to,
rather than having the law
dictated most of, most of the time,
I think Google should just make
those decisions to say, yeah,
we're not going to link to revenge porn.
So if there's a revenge porn link
out there and we're notified,
we're going to take that link down,
which I think they do now. But great.
Well this is a good transition
to questions. Uh, if you,
if your questions, there are two
microphones on either side and since, uh,
since we need to to this to
go on video, um, questions,
does anybody have questions? Yes, please.
Hi.
I was wondering what the relationship was
between a Wiki Tribune and Wikipedia'd
or what the intended goal relationship is.
Yeah, so we can do view it as a completely
new organization and there is no
relationship at all. Uh, I'm on
the board of both, but that's it.
And the reason I did it that way,
it's one of the things that's fantastic
about the world of Wikipedia, uh,
is that all decisions get made through
a very long process of community
consultation and deliberation,
which means we're very
slow and making decisions,
but we tend to make very good decisions.
Uh,
this is a startup where I'm going to
have to change the website like 10 times
quite radically as we figure
out what's working, what isn't.
And it wasn't really possible to
even launch something like this.
It'd be a massive sort of two year
consultation and I wanted to just move
quickly. So that's what we're
doing it this way. Other questions
and Jimmy are both, thanks very much
for an interesting conversation. Um,
you mentioned that when you were,
you live in London and I think
the foundation is based in the UK.
The UK also has famously restrictive
and gruesome libel laws that massively
restrict freedom of expression.
Is there any kind of risk for the
foundation for that or is this,
I'm going to irony in there
to basically right there.
Okay. So the Jimmy Wells
Foundation is based in the UK,
a completely separate organization.
And we get to have too many organizations
we contribute is based in the UK. Uh,
and then the Wikimedia foundation, which
runs Wikipedia is in California. Um,
so on the,
on the libel law front for Wiki Tribune,
the law has changed recently in the
UK. Uh, it's become a lot better,
but it's still by no means
as good as a in the US.
Uh,
but I,
I'm not that worried about it because
we want to be really like very high
quality, very neutral, very fact based.
Obviously there's always a risk
of a lawsuit of course. Uh,
but if the daily mail can survive
without being sued out of existence,
I imagine we'll be all right.
Right here please.
What's your plans for a scope and scale
of the first year? How many stories,
like on an average day
would you want to happen?
Wiki Trivia, um, don't really know. Uh,
we want to have just as much as possible,
but without compromising quality.
So there are a lot of
interesting open question.
So right now because we've just launched,
um,
basically what we say is that the
community and the staff are equals,
but that doesn't mean that everybody
is the editor in chief. Um,
and so we do have editors who approve
things before they're published and they
treat the journalists and the
staff is equal in that regard.
So right now we're being a little bit
slow about what we're putting out because
we want it to be good quality. Part of
that is I wouldn't do it this way if,
if I weren't a well known personal ready,
but I know that a lot of people
who at the Daily Mail for example,
are just waiting for us to publish some
error to just sort of take us down a
notch and we'd rather be battered,
held to high standard from day one.
Whereas Wikipedia was not held to
high standard from day one, uh,
because nobody knew what we were doing.
Nobody cared.
They were like very tiny little group
of people on an obscure corner of the
Internet.
Eventually though,
I think we want to open it up to
have stories published quite quickly.
A lot of open ended things.
I'm happy to have short little stub
articles that are just like quick updates
rather than a fully composed piece. So,
but to be determined to be determined.
So I'm going to take another one here.
We have two more here and I just want to
make sure everyone gets their questions
answered because we're
going to run at a time.
Hey Jimmy.
I used to do some work on the Wikipedia
signposts and I was wondering to what
extent that may have influenced Wiki
Tribune, that Wikipedia signposts as,
I don't know,
when is say an on Wikipedia
sort of newspaper that's
been around for at least a
decade,
probably a decade and a half.
Um, to some extent. Yeah.
Because it's uh, uh,
I mean obviously I read the signpost,
uh,
and sort of goes into my thinking about
what communities can do a and the sign
posts generally,
uh,
generally or reports on internal goings
on at Wikipedia as well as things that
would be of interest to the community
outside and tries to be neutral and fair
and so on. And I think it's quite good.
Uh, I can't say it directly inspired me,
but honestly it's just a part
of my world yet. Here please.
Hi. So I'd like to go back on
fact checking in on Wikipedia.
If you could comment a bit more,
what happens when somebody
added sort of obscure,
difficult to check facts?
Like, uh, for example,
you have census data for some
small county in us let's say,
which is not easy to check and
maybe does that trigger a signal,
an email to the moderators or do you
have a minimum amount of edits that are
needed be done before that triggers an
alert that perhaps somebody is making
significant changes? Um, you know,
I specifically liked on the same how you
check the numbers because I use that to
my project.
Yeah.
Um,
so generally there's not much
algorithmic signaling of people. Um,
so editors have a watch list and they can
flag the things that are interested to
watch and then they're notified
when something changes there.
Normally what we would say is
we will ask for the source.
So then you have to link to the
source and then you know, it,
it may be hard to find the source,
but once you found the
source and you link to it,
it's quite easy for other people
that go and evaluate it and say, oh,
well this is from, uh, the
government of this area.
Uh,
it was published at the state.
It seems like legitimate
formation and that sort of thing.
It's quite old fashioned,
really. There's nothing,
sometimes these resources
aren't online though. So like,
since was data from the 18 hundreds? Yeah.
Yeah. So for sources that aren't online,
uh, we consider that to be valid.
Uh, there's, there's no rule there.
I actually sometimes get caught in,
I find it incredibly annoying. Uh,
I get quoted and people love to make
like these beautiful kind of pluck cards
with this quote saying, if it isn't
in Google, it doesn't exist. Um, okay.
Those words came out of my mouth only to
make fun of that view of the world. Uh,
and so I'm like, that's not really
fair to quote me as saying that. Um,
so it's basically the,
um,
uh, it's, it's, it's, there's
no, nothing special, no nothing.
I can really tell you if,
if you're a well known contributor and
you're known to be someone who works in
that area and you're
trusted by the community,
that would be completely accepted if the
information you're putting in seams in
some way. Surprising. So you're,
you're saying the population of uh,
uh, Miami, Florida was 43
million people in 1870,
we'd probably go, yeah, probably not. And
challenge it. Um, and then in between,
I think we would tend to
trust if it's obscured,
like what motive would you have
for making up population numbers?
That's a question that we go through
people's minds and the, the source there,
there will be people in Wikipedia who
their hobby is population figures in the
18 hundreds,
and they will have some idea as to
whether it corroborates with the General
Dadada nothing magical about it.
Um,
it's just trying to do
the best job we can.
Kids or I want to just get your
through the rest of the questions.
Please go ahead and trying to throw.
So this relates to the
previous question on scope,
but it's a good way in which news source
success bias is not only the two of the
articles,
but also which stories that she used to
cover and what prominence they choose to
assign them.
So is there any way that would get your
billing plans to address this issue?
I think this is,
this is where having a healthy on
diverse community is very helpful.
Um, because community members can
start stories about anything they want.
And so the problem of a small team of
an editorial board who have a certain
perspective on the world, even if they're
trying to be neutral, obviously one the,
you know,
one of the facts about biases,
oftentimes we are biased in ways that
we don't even notice because that's what
bias is. Right? Um, and so having
a diverse community who says, hey,
we need to write about this.
This is an important story that's
not being covered elsewhere.
And they couldn't rally volunteers
to do that, then then they should.
And I think we have to
be very introspective,
always about our internal
staff processes to say,
are we just choosing
stories? Um, you know,
so like in today's political environment,
you might only choose stories about Donald
Trump and Russia and not true stories
about Hillary and her emails. That's
just one simple example, which is,
I know what you've always got to
challenge yourself and say, right,
we need to make sure we're looking
at things. It's actually one of the,
I have a whole little rant about Fox
News and I haven't lived in the u s in a
long time, uh, for eight
years. And even before that,
I wasn't a big watcher of Fox News
because I don't watch much television.
But one of the things I think a lot of
people missed when they thought Fox News
was incredibly biased,
which of course it is in certain ways,
is most of the shows people talked about.
Our opinion shows it's bill O'Reilly
pontificating and having guests in,
but they're straight news segments.
Uh, we're actually quite high quality,
but they often covered stories that
people in the heartland cared about.
The people in New York and California
weren't that interested in and that was
one of the reasons they became very
popular. They would cover a story, uh,
that just seemed like, you know, whatever
factory workers out of work somewhere,
you know,
maybe we near comes covers it.
But they were like
really in there in a way.
And I think that's important is one of
the reasons I think we've had this huge
drop in trust in the media
is a lot of people read,
followed immediate and they're
like, well, this, I don't know,
this has nothing to do with my life.
Nobody's really covering it.
And when we look at the
incredible devastation has
happened to local newspapers
everywhere, you can actually
see why people feel like, Hey,
journalism doesn't care about me.
They're basically,
all they do is rant about Trump. Nobody's
like concerned about our problems here.
Um, so I, I'm, we have like
two speed dating questions.
So let's take the two questions here
and if we can, we'll just take one more.
I'm really concerned about time.
They're, they're starting to like,
I would love to, yes. Every question.
Like they say Jimmy. No, no, no.
[inaudible] and thank you. Thank you.
This question is for four week explicitly.
Um,
it seems to me part of the success of
Wikipedia is the quality of the community.
How are you going about building
the community and making sure it is?
Thank you.
And so first of all,
and we're welcoming everyone
and we're welcoming all of you.
And we're lucky to have Jamie to have
experience of building an online community
of contributors.
So we are also aware of all their
possible problems that might occur.
We don't want it to be UK based
or US based or you're just,
you know,
West centric.
And that's why we plan to launch in as
many languages as possible in as many
regions as possible to start
dissolving. You know, they're all,
I'm focused on, on, on, you know,
you were talking about Trump and Hillary.
There are so many more stories around
the world were happening. You know,
we have Tara taxing Egypt and so on
that people do talk about maybe an oddly
enough maybe you know,
a lot of corruptions in different new on
Columbia in different countries that I
don't think they get enough focus.
That's why am personally I have the
background, a few in rights law.
So personally I'm very interested in
having a very diverse community and from
big different background for
gender, you know, gender wise,
I know that Wikipedia has some
problem with not enough women, um,
editing the entries.
So we are very aware of the
palms that war or still existing,
they Wikipedia and we're trying to avoid
them or sold them before they happened.
And,
and so it is a challenge.
Of course I don't have all
the answers yet, but um, we,
we can adopt some of the solutions that
were already farmed in Wikipedia and
maybe we will find new once a diversity.
I think it's a very important for the
neutrality part of Jimmy spoke about a,
but for many more things,
um,
that are important for very
sustainable use side. That's going to,
and I turned all issues and relate
to as many people as possible.
We want to change journalists and we don't
want to replicate what already exists.
Yeah.
So we're going to,
I know I'm running over time,
they're going to like get the hook soon,
but I want to make sure we get out the
answers. Questions. Amazing. Duck sweater.
Please go ahead.
So I guess bringing it back
to a Wikipedia question,
you've mentioned how important
the community is and you
kind of just mentioned
some of the maybe biases or
differences about that. Um,
a specific question I had is,
do you think that the
community of contributors is
going to be aging over time
with Wikipedia or are you
seeing a lot of kind of newer,
younger people come in common?
I guess if you have any insight into other
trials of any kind of diversity there?
Yeah, in terms of Wikipedia,
the, uh, the, it's a,
it's a concern, but it's not
an overwhelming concern. So
we do see, we've got a, uh,
a very large cohort of very active,
very powerful users who've been
around for a long time. Uh,
but we also have new contributors
would come in all the time. Uh,
if we don't have good data on the aging.
My feeling is that the Wikipedia
community has been aging. Uh,
sort of the average age has been going
up about a quarter of a year every year
or something like that. Uh, so we are
aging, but it's not like we're all,
we're not going up by one year per
year. Uh, so there is that. Um,
and yeah, final question please. Yeah.
So my question is just around,
uh, she can use and you know,
large by the fake news problem is
that people are just consuming news,
an echo chamber.
So I'm just curious about how Wiki
Tribune plants to tackle that and any
thoughts you have right now.
Yes,
I think I was just talking about that,
that we are going to
attend to more communities.
It also going to local
communities as well. Uh,
we're searching for a lot of models
to get as many diverse people and
communities and backgrounds and involved.
Yeah. I think one of the,
one of the key elements here,
one of the reasons we're
launching with no ads is like the,
the advertising model drives a certain
sameness to the stories that are covered.
If you're chasing clicks,
you need to have a headline about
something that people are already excited
about and know about.
So you're going to get a lot more clicks.
Our business model,
what I need,
I need you to read to the
bottom of a piece and say, wow,
I didn't see that anywhere
else. I understand the world
better than I did before.
This deserves to exist. I should ship
in a, I should, I should pay for this.
Um, versus if I were at driven,
I just need you to come and look.
And that means it doesn't drive you in
the direction of trying to wow people
with like, oh wow, I didn't know
about that. And how did I miss that?
This is something new. So I think
that's a part of the answer, uh,
is to set up the business model so that
the organization's internal focus is on
something different from
what everybody else is doing.
So this has been a great conversation
we could go on for a long time,
and, uh, and I'm sure the folks at Google
really appreciate it, so thank you both.
Yeah.
Okay.